in dieses Viertel in Bangkok bringt dich
nicht jeder Taxifahrer die Rede ist von
Klong Toy dem größten slamgebiet
Thailand geschätzt leben hier 120 000
Menschen teilweise zu über 10 Personen
in kleinen Blechhütten im Internet wird
gewarnt man SLE diese Gegend als Tourist
meinen damals in der Schule haben wir
über viele Slums weltweit gesprochen
aber selber vor Ort in einem war ich
noch nie deswegen hatte ich natürlich
gemischte Gefühle auf der einen Seite
war ich gespannt aber ich hatte auch
Respekt hinter dem Klong Toy market auf
dem jeden Tag jede Menge Fisch und
Fleisch verkauft wird sowas habe ich by
the way in diesem Ausmaß auch noch nie
gesehen erstreckt sich auf 260 Hektar
der SL Anfang der 1950er Jahre wurden
unweit des Hafens von Bangkok günstige
Arbeitskräfte besucht die sich in
einfachen Hütten nicht weit vom Hafen
entfernt ansiedeln so entstand hier über
Jahre ein richtiges gassensystem neben
Hütten im Freien gibt es viele enge Wege
an die weitere Hütten anknüpfen manchmal
landet man in Sackgassen manchmal kommt
man aber auch an großen Plätzen raus
hier spielen die Bewohner dann so ein
volleyballfußball ich durfte übrigens
mal mitspielen außerdem führt eine
Zugstrecke direkt durch den Land so wie
ich das verstanden habe kommt der Zug
aber nur einmal die Woche die Bewohner
waren unfassbar nett und haben sich
super über unseren Besuch gefreut eine
Erfahrung die ich definitiv